here welcome to this video this is the
third part of this miniseries about the
London system and yet from the black
side battling the London system which
means all kinds of setup this Bishop f4
quickly in the first videos the first
one we mainly looked at this kind of
stuff where black played an early d7 d5
the second video was about like playing
Knight f6 and g6 so he's heading for
King's Indian or gruul felt mostly and
this video will be looking at this
version of the London system uh Black
has played 90 f6 and e6 oh he's heading
for um NIMS Oh Queens Indian BOGO Indian
type of setup um down here again white
can play Bishop f4 um yeah
black has some two principal ways to to
play this now we can play at some point
d5 anyway and transpose into a d4 d5
opening um but you don't have the
possibility to get your Bishop out as I
described in the first video in the
first video my recommendation was to to
actually M avoid the movie 6 for a while
so that you at some point even can play
Bishop f5 so in the video here with e6
some it's simply not possible to develop
this Bishop anymore so I think as this
is a key point in the in this opening um
it's a good idea to take care about the
bishop immediately and play b6 I feared
shadowing this piece of course as
mentioned d5 is possible but it leads to
entirely different um positions then I
examined previously cell b6
yeah white now usually play some III or
c3 at some it's very similar you should
to be 792 should eat seven see three
castles this is all very normal and wide
very often also place h3 so this is
basically all the same you can
interchange those move some and play
various moves order that's right but it
leads to the same kind of position all
the time
um yeah now look at next position he's
suddenly a content with his pieces here
you should on b7 is good Bishop on e7 is
solid so what about the center pause C
and D pawn what I actually like him to
play a certain place c5 keep the bishop
the the pawn on them d7 and move the
bishop pony with c5 what usually goes
for Bishop d3 and here black has two two
ways to go about this okay he's got more
than two ways but two ways I'd like to
to show briefly the first one is what
would I play myself here and this is to
take on D form
I like to exchange on D for him white in
the vast majority of games recaptures
with deep on and we look at C takes D em
later
and after this my own recommendation is
to set up on ya a headshot formation
with a 66 b6 Center probably in a6 and
this is in fact I'm a pretty good setup
for black here the point is look at this
that this wall of pawns pretty much
hinders wide from making any concrete
progress iam especially in the d66 pawns
so the center nicely and white doesn't
have a really concrete idea how to
improve his position in fact this is
often um a problem in this London system
positions that white can easily make ten
moves 15 moves and have all his pieces
out but then you ask yourself if you're
white okay what am I taking now what is
my big plan and this is in fact the
problem that why to your faces it
doesn't have already made plan in this
position cannot really play for any
meaningful palm break whereas black gown
in fact has some ideas and one idea of
that black has is to push me five and
this can be can be prepared also let's
say let's just put a put a couple of
moves on the board rook e1 rook e8 look
let's say d1 we should invade this is a
typical maneuver with them this idea
will be five in mind the rook on the
eight being opposed to the Queen and
sometimes you can play Queen c7 to
support this this e5 move and it's not
so clear what white is doing here in
this position it's not like black is
better but you have ideas you can push
this pawn another idea could be as black
to play b5 and control the c-4 square
and also with beef b5 preparing Knight
b6 to d5 so you can combine all these
ideas but if I've especially can be a
very tricky move for Y to meet as those
pieces are on all in all kinds of forks
because why should a black should play
Queen c7 first so on let's say here here
and then if I from it gets really am
yeah it's a possibility
coming up sometimes you can even click
go into c6 and prepare this move for
example a for Quincy six is not bad
what is white doing now he covers this
then you can even think about it five
I'm just want to show the ideas I'm not
sure if it is so great in this concrete
position but this is one idea to prepare
this move and it leads to a fighting
position the head shop here in fact is a
bit different than the other head shocks
as the deep one which is usually on a
half-open file yeah here is not on that
hub open file the fact white doesn't
have any pressure on horns you know this
cornwall i think this is a pretty good
version of the head shock even if you
don't play this in other kinds of
openings you should seriously consider
this as it's a very flexible setup and
you have some some ideas effect and so
let's return and one thing you also need
to look at at least briefly as if you
take on deform and then white can also
capture with the c-pawn and this is
something something else of course
because now the C file is this open and
my recommendation would be to play a set
up with knight c6 and d6 you want to put
the nylon c6 to block the C file I set
up with 97 isn't so great because it
gives the C file open and white maybe
has some chances like this to invade and
then I don't see six simply blocks this
and something like this could be a
possible continuation just put it on the
board and now a black shouldn't play d5
release wouldn't be so great but you can
you can easily play something like this
going to d7 and then try to double on
the C file it's rather flexible and
white against this small Center cannot
use any of the center square so like
it's fairly solid it's pretty simply
similar to this head shop information
that I should be form only on the C file
it is some yeah there's always the
possibility of some exchanges laid out
so it's not as unbalanced as the
at the other position in fact it is a
question here and this will set up when
should like take on deform um a case
could be made in fact if you look at
this to start with c5 this is an equally
good move order and if you don't like so
much to play against this in this seat
XD 4c takes default scenario then maybe
c5 immediately is the better movers
right much more often place III than c3
in this position so III you can even
consider taking now and go will be six
it's really similar
why doesn't really have any great way to
improve from upon the moves that I just
put on the board in the line before so
white ball will still play a let's say
this kind of this kind of moves oops
Jake here D 3 C 3 and so on it's
basically the same position why it
doesn't have anything else um or better
significantly better than this moves I
don't know C 3 here you can even think
about other setups of here if you want
you can take and like we'd be sicker so
some rather interesting way to play this
attacking the pawn and this can pretty
quickly lead to a good position for
black one example being a queen c2 which
can with the pawn then ninety six is a
good idea
attacking on d4 III and now the very
concrete move Knight to one to B form
and this is in fact a bit annoying form
for white already as some this night
will go to d5 give you one example Queen
C 1 and then Knight to d5
now this Bishop is detect and M it needs
to be moved um and let's say Bishop here
then like as they're interesting
possible
in 94 which gets this idea into play we
should be for check and you can also see
also threaten to take it
so whiter I think needs to react them to
to both these ideas you cannot simply
add develop yeah you can but it's simply
and then you get forget the Bishop s as
mentioned let's say here here and then
the normal move yeah and like has some
gained her the bishop pair and managed
to get some imbalance and to the
position and it's rather interesting to
to play in this way this all is he takes
deform so maybe this move water is it's
a recommendation what you always need to
be cautious about this in these kind of
setups the Queen b6 move if the center
situation hasn't been clarified here
moves like Knight a3 with this idea on
Knight c3 young are both are very tricky
so this is really to be avoided this
only Queen excluder Queen Saudis do to
grab pawns it's really a different story
in this position as the center is much
more standing now and white really am
and doesn't have such a comfortable move
to to to play if you go here then it's
interesting what what like should play
you can take on me too
but this might get tricky after Bishop
d2 so on it's always a bit risky this
kind of pawn reps let's say here would
be one and maybe you need to go on go
all the way back and yeah white has had
some compensation for the pawn so need
to be cautious as mentioned you can
always play in the fashion that I am
they're described at the beginning and
but this all ec5 can be a can be a good
ideas after III takes you get the
desired a symmetrical bone structure and
after c3 you can still continue b6 and
get to the first line that I that I
showed but this idea as mentioned is
interesting to get to get a bit more
yeah bit of yeah a more a trickier
position let's say were white faces some
concrete problems um in this move order
here white also has some alternatives
like c3 and then Bishop f4 and this
isn't really a difference you can still
play b6 on or c5 it's it's just the same
if white plays Bishop Airfone later and
also it should look quickly at this move
order again if you you're not playing
g6 setups but ecigs then you will
probably play this move now and III g 6
or c5 will invariably transpose to what
we looked at before as white really
doesn't have anything else they're not
f3 in this position are probably this
move but then you can also simply
continue with v6 em and Bishop d7 it's a
lot much of a difference simply because
we're out should the light go then to f3
so white will play this Knight f3 move
from in the near future it can play this
but now you really need to and then
after Bishop d7 d3 and take here or
first this this kind of stuff you can
take again and have your desired
position I hope you desired is the right
word I like to play this the this head
chop setups are in this this structure
it's really a different story than
and this is sewing head shock or the
English head shock where you need to be
aware of the pressure on the deep one
and so on this is not really happening
here
yeah in fact this is almost the end of
the series I thought three videos would
be a would be all right and we have got
everything covered but then I am
actually remembered that probably I
should do a fourth video a quick one
which addresses some other moves after
1d for the white plays Bishop f4 anyway
and this mostly covers stuff like d6g 6
and and probably I'm probably even the
Dutch yeah but this will be a nun in the
4th video that will complete this
serious yeah
I hope you enjoyed this look at two legs
ideas in this line and you're not yeah
afraid or annoyed um about them about
facing the London it's often not much
fun because it's so solid so it's very
difficult to to break down but if you
know a good setup and I hope I am I show
them I demonstrated a couple then you
will get a fun position after the
opening and then you need to be your
patient and creative and then you can
still win the game of course yeah thanks
for watching I hope you enjoyed it